over the last month i've been reviewing
the first 2.5 parts of jojo's bizarre
adventure
all of which i had seen before however
today marks a starting point for when i
start covering material i've never seen
everything from here on out is entirely
new to me and this story is one of the
most legendary and iconic arcs in manga
history and now that i finally finished
this long sprawling journey across the
world with jotaro and his crew
all i can say is what an adventure and
what a finish since last week's video
focused heavily on the philosophy and
circumstances surrounding this curious
story's creation
this week i thought it might be fun to
break down the story in greater detail
and to explore my favorite stand battles
from this entire part
next week i'll be covering diamond is
unbreakable but right now let's dive
from one last time
into the climax to the ambitious popular
and heartbreaking second half to the
emphatic conclusion to jojo's bizarre
adventures
legendary final act in a trilogy
spanning three generations
this is the tragic the epic and the
staggering finale
to stardust crusaders
[Music]
all right so as i said last week the
story in the first half isn't really
anything worth writing home about
after the initial setup which saw
jodoro's mother holly fall ill thanks to
her stan magic
jose and his fans joined egypt using
their stand magic and once they get to
egypt
they realize dio isn't there and they
have to travel and fight some more using
their stand magic
until eventually we get to the big fight
with dio at the very end where they will
finally get to see
his stand magic last week i didn't
really get to cover much concretely
within the story and so this week before
i dive straight into the second half's
material i will first rampage my way
through and break down all of my
favorite stand battles
from the first half are you ready let's
do that strength early on in the story
there were plenty of introductory
battles from the skies to the water but
none of the early stand battles taught
me more about the possibilities that
this new mechanic offers
than chapters 17 18 and 19 all
entitled strength typically speaking
after a half decade of studying
narrative theory i like many others in
my position
tend to get a sense of what direction
the story is going to take and
so when a story can shock or surprise me
in ways i wasn't expecting
that really means a lot to me and
greatly heightens my personal
experiences
and boy did this one surprise me with
jojo and the rest of the stardust
crusaders on a small boat in the middle
of the south china sea somewhere
after yeah some stuff happens
suddenly as if by magic our heroes seem
to have caught a break or
so we thought a giant ship without
anyone seemingly on board appears as if
from nowhere
granting them access aboard what i loved
about this short encounter wasn't
necessarily the nature of the fighting
or the thrill of the stakes or anything
like that really but more so as soon as
i saw this
i knew something was up from the get-go
i knew that it had something to do with
a new stand user pretty much every
single scene we've been a part of since
the beginning has introduced us to a new
stand in one form or another
but this one really felt different and
it was
there's a sort of creepy horror element
that becomes all the more apparent
once it's revealed that the orangutan in
the cargo hold has in fact been behind
the entire event and has a weird
creepy scene in a shower with a girl
that i will absolutely pretend didn't
happen
in favor of praising how great it was
when jotaro beat the bananas out of that
great ape
his stand was the ship and while short
and it eventually becoming very clear
what's going on
it still impressed me and surprised me
with how robust the stand system was
it's definitely one of the few battles
that stuck in my memory after i finished
and it only got crazier from
that was your job you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] that's why you are a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it was a joke mark i should also mention
that i won't be touching on every single
stand battle in this act if i did this
video would be a million years long
and besides i don't really have anything
much to say about most of them
other than they happened or they were
weird or i wish i hadn't seen that
i do however like that since these stand
encounters are so numerous they offer
plenty in the way of occasion for the
side characters to establish themselves
and to get some shine too
opportunities that up until now have
only been enjoyed by the main characters
really i know that the gang have managed
to battle their way across the south
china sea into singapore
jotaro joseph kakuin abdul and poneriff
finally found themselves on the indian
portion of their trip
as they arrive in calcutta where one of
my favorite fights
takes place jay gael hangman
this was the fight that really impressed
me both from a creativity
implementation and visual points of view
this encounter involving kakween and
polymeric
really demonstrated the utility of these
side characters how to develop them in
the middle of action
and to let their personalities shine
through while this scene partially
involves another stand user utilizing a
ghost gun
who can wanted his bullets around
obstacles like angelina jolie the vast
majority of the intrigue for this
section can rest on the shoulders
of this one stand
yeah it's uh it's pretty creepy and even
more so in the manga and on top of
having an
awesome design this dude can only be
seen and can only
operate in the reflection of various
objects and surfaces
mirrors shards of glass the reflection
of a piece of metal
a person's eyeball let me repeat that
it hides in the reflection and attacks
within the person's eyeball and tries to
kill someone
this thing is absolutely crazy and much
like the battle on the ghost ship
this fight reinforces for me why the
concept of stanz works so ridiculously
well in a series like this
you can take any scenario be it mundane
or action-packed and whether or not you
think you know how this is going to play
out
i assure you you don't and let's not
forget
this hangman guy works as a team with
this
gun-toting guy who shoots and kills
abdul
this is where the narrative is helped
greatly by this particular choice
polynomial is the sole reason why they
are in this scenario and why abdul had
to die
abdul had told polymer if not to chase
after this person who killed his sister
oh yeah i forgot to tell you
this guy killed uh a polymeric sister
dick move
now on top of already endangering his
friends polymorph now has to contend
with the choices he's made that led to
his friend's demise
it's honestly quite sad and from a
narrative point of view a great choice
i didn't think abdul was offering much
to the party and whenever a character
starts to feel
dull or or stops contributing something
has to be done and
i'm glad he got the axe here if that
makes sense well
i mean i'm not happy he died but from a
sterile clinical narrative theory point
of view i'm happy they left him cold in
the ground
what's wrong with you but yeah while the
combined efforts of kakween and
polynomial ultimately get the better of
this hangman the combination of humor
crazy set pieces
and action really helped this fight
stand out amidst the others for me it's
a terrific
section something also worth mentioning
is a narrative i've seen prop up every
now and then is that jotaro is sort of
an overpowered meathead that could have
done
all of this on his own i could not
disagree more with that line of thinking
uh joduro is a competent and
level-headed guy in a pinch but when it
comes to discretion
and or approaching and figuring out a
situation
he needs and often relies on his friends
like he wouldn't have made it at all
this far without them now fast forward a
number of unsavory stand encounters
later and we land on an island somewhere
in the middle of the red sea
this is where we meet cameo and judgment
throughout this seemingly never-ending
journey across the asian continent and
into africa it's honestly a pleasure
watching the heroes of this story combat
all sorts of interesting characters like
the sun all the while in these
constantly differing surroundings
but none were prettier to me than the
jungle slash savannah of this remote
island where palmyra once again
encounters a new enemy stand
judgement and while i'm talking about
him polaroid in this first half seems to
be getting an absurd amount of exposure
compared to the rest of the cast and
i'm including jonaro in that somewhat
too the island they land on is
supposedly that of the late abdul's
father
if the resemblance didn't sell that fact
enough already this stand battle again
is sort of a fun one given the nature of
this dan's abilities a sort of a spin or
twist on the monkey's paw
myth where it acts as a genie that can
grant any wish but
the wishes get all sorts of messed up
and i mean
really messed up like i'm talking
polymer of sister and friend abdul
coming back to life only to try and kill
him and if that wasn't screwy enough
that's when this happens
all right so abdul's alive and it turns
out that all the things we saw and heard
jojo say about burying him was
a lie and that not only has he been
following them this entire time but also
that guy we saw and thought was the
father of abdul was actually just abdul
in disguise
this is hilarious and cool but i think
abdul dying in that way
made more sense for his character he
instilled a lasting impression on a
number of his friends
and made the journey feel that much more
perilous substantively speaking
his return as well as the unveiling and
eventual overcoming of cameo stan powers
are really what breathes life into the
section but i'm not sure if i like the
idea of abdul coming back
from the dead in this particular section
i'm not sure if it adds that much
the person who made this save could very
easily have been jotaro and it would
have been just as impressive at least to
me
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you what's wrong with you
you and almost immediately after that we
hop into the next and last
suspense-filled outing before
egypt the high priestess parts one to
four
these are the final four chapters in the
first half of this journey before jotaro
and his merry band of mitzvahs finally
arrive at egypt and the final enemy
stand that we meet
is this guy uh from a visuals
perspective
at least initially it didn't strike me
as particularly visually engaging and
felt somewhat derivative
and based on past less successful stands
like the weird blob creature that grew
inside of joseph's arm beef earlier
in the series however what this part of
the story does fantastically well
is manipulating and abusing tension
now sinking deeper and deeper into the
ocean the gang had decided to travel in
a submarine
next to reach their goal they have
crashed a number of planes cars and
boats in this time and so what better
way for them to complete their
catastrophe bingo
in a safe fashion than in a large highly
pressurized
underwater vessel jokes aside while this
stand doesn't look that impressive
initially eventually it becomes a giant
face
and eats them all which is way more
impressive looking than when it started
out and funnily enough
while it did start out unremarkable to
look at it did so with a bang by ripping
off joseph's prosthetic arm
now that they are all eaten and stuck
under the ocean within this
face with no chance of escape jojo looks
to have been
crushed
and that's pretty much the first half i
honestly liked it a lot more than i
thought it would given that it's
episodic and the divide it's created
within the community but honestly it
forced me to put on my historian hat for
the first time
perhaps ever and to look at this series
as a case study for the late 1980s in
japan's manga industry
it's taught me so much more than any
part of any story i've ever reviewed
before
and even if i look at it from my own
individual point of view the creativity
and mystery that the stans introduced to
the story as well as the camaraderie
built over the course
of this extensive adventure really
helped to sell me on
and engage me as a reader but who cares
apparently
a ludicrously large amount of jojo fans
prefer the second half over the first
and
i know that because i took a poll on my
twitter apparently like 90
of people prefer the second half so
let's dive into that and if you guys
want to be part of future polls follow
me on twitter but as i said
the second half is where everything goes
down so let's see what i thought of it
the second half as soon as they arrive
in egypt the status quo is shaken up to
make things a little more interesting
the speedwagon foundation lands to give
them intellendio specific whereabouts
the status and holly
and supplies to make their way through
the desert more manageable
oh and to bring iggy to the party
iggy is a dog that has a stand and to be
perfectly honest i was sort of scared
that they were going to give this dog
speaking lines and i'm very happy that
they didn't the very fact that he's
largely silent endeared me to him
quite a lot now the fight that erupts
almost immediately after iggy's
introduction to the party is a
relatively exciting and
interesting battle with one of dio's
nine stand users that each represent one
of the egyptian gods
mark is now incorrectly going to refer
to endure as endow
for the rest of the video enjoy endow is
the first and provides a nice excuse to
fill us the audience in and what's to
come ahead and to show us what iggy can
do
one thing i found that was a little
forced was the nature with which this
bad guy does eventually meet his end
he decides to kill himself when he knew
he had no other chance
lest he divulge information to jotaro's
party about dio and you know what that's
fair enough
but then he goes on to tell them stuff
about the situation with dio
it's thanks to him they know that the
nine stand users are manifestations of
the egyptian gods
it seems like you didn't do what you
said you were supposed to do there guy
oingo boingo and bastet this is
a really cool idea for a team of stand
users
when i first heard about the concept of
stands i really wasn't all that enthused
in my mind i sort of saw them as
glorified pokemon battles only instead
of six monsters fighting by your side
you have only one and in thinking that
way i had totally missed the point of
what stands
are and where their strengths lie they
are all mystery boxes waiting to be
opened whenever a new stand user makes
himself or herself known there's a
number of anticipations but none perhaps
more interesting than how that user will
use his or her stand
and how that will force the heroes to
fight in other words it's possible that
you can get tired of constant pokemon
battles because they can be somewhat
predictable
however when it comes to stands the
nature of how the specifics in the
altercations play out
is entirely different almost every time
and few are more out there than the
brotherly team of oingo and
boingo with oingo possessing a stand
that can alter his appearance and boingo
who possesses a stand that can predict
the near future through comic panels
and while other encounters are quite
formulaic as i mentioned the variety in
how these formulas play out are so
diverse it that while i was reading i
found myself to
get honestly excited to see what the
next stand would be on the horizon not
to even mention how the heroes would
react to it where other battles are
quite serious others like this are
honestly fun
and filled with slapstick watching these
two brothers try to manipulate the
future to their benefit all the while
jotaro and co
don't even realize they're trying to
take them out it's a really fun idea for
a short story and one that ended blowing
up in the face of the bad guys
and even after this with stands like
anubis and bassette these are all
variations on previously spoken about
formulas of this episodically structured
arc
i mentioned power rangers last week as
an example of formulaic or episodic
storytelling that comparison was just
really to explain the concept however
one thing i want to avoid
is making it sound like jojo and power
rangers share anything in common besides
their episodic nature while the
structure of the encounters largely
remain the same or are consistent
throughout the variations and creativity
implemented with
how these encounters take place are
almost entirely unpredictable in other
words there are no such issues in this
department with stardust crusaders
chapter after chapter i continue to be
blown away by the means with which araki
has creatively told this story i mean
the sixth chapter encounter with the
bassett stand user was honestly
incredibly well handled if someone were
to come to me with the concept of this
stand with it
increasing your magnetic pull slowly
over time you'd naturally think it to be
boring but araki managed to make that
one of the most
memorable fights in the series for me
watching joseph slowly become attracted
to larger and larger pieces of metal
while losing more and more control over
the situation was not only funny at
times but quite tense as the snowball
effect continued to cascade down the
mountain
it's a terrific idea for a power and it
only gets better from here
the darby brothers if there's any battle
in the story that highlights the upside
that these stands bring to the table
it's the battle for lost souls
with the darby brothers unlike all the
other stan battles the first of the two
brothers battles doesn't revolve around
direct contact it's something much more
interesting and while i was reading
through this section
my heart was in my stomach the means
with which this section of the story
caters to its big finish
is fundamental but exceptionally well
orchestrated and not to mention fun
kicking things off darby the gambler
gains the attention of joseph joestar by
admitting that he knows the whereabouts
of dio brando and eventually the team
gets sucked into a series of gambling
games
in exchange for the information derby
demands that players bet their souls
it seems straightforward and honestly it
is but what adds spice to this simple
conflict is that darby the gambler is a
swindler someone that is incredibly
adept at cheating without getting
caught and this becomes apparent
throughout the games with ponderoff and
joseph joestar respectively with the
latter showing us just how far derby is
willing to take things in cheating and
demonstrates that if the
player has lost in his mind then the
soul exits his body anyway
i don't want to spoil the actual games
that are played because i really want to
encourage anyone who hasn't checked out
this series
or this section to definitely check it
out it's very very fun they are
tremendously well
crafted pieces of competitive story
writing and the ultimate battle between
derby and jodaroa was honestly
at this point in the arc my absolute
favorite battle in the series
and to think it was just a game of poker
the way it's paneled the way it's told
and the way it climaxes is a phenomenal
culmination of the building blocks that
the prior two gambling games set up
check this one out if you haven't
already it's amazing
i think the funny thing about this arc
specifically is that while i can
understand and empathize with those that
label all of those stand battles as
stalling tactics leading up to the one
and only fight that matters in diobrando
finally coming into conflict with the
jojo family
i can't help but ignore all of it
because the vast majority of these stand
battles particularly in the second half
ranging from what i've already spoken
about like the likes of oingo boingo and
dao bassette and derby the gambler
providing a range of different and
unique battles that honestly couldn't
have happened in any other series on to
what i haven't spoken about like the
unlikely team of a boingo and hull horse
and the thrilling battle between iggy
and pet shop the latter of which made me
care so much more about this little dog
i mean
in the manga apart from where he's first
used against endow iggy doesn't really
play that large of a role but
in this outing specifically he's the
courageous one and takes out one very
dangerous stand user in pet shop
sustaining significant injury in the
process
but enough blustering is time to go on
to the next darby brother the second and
final one
darby the player
they've reached their goal and this is
where the second and final derby brother
makes himself
known darby the player funnily enough
the two brothers while they share the
same sort of power in that they steal
souls from their opponents their
respective philosophies are
mirror images of one another one cheats
and one plays by the rules
sort of where derby the gambler played
much more traditional old school games
like
poker or games of chance this brother on
the other hand likes to take things with
a much more modern approach
video games stealing kakuin away in a
creepy doll
and oh yeah this dude collects creepy
dolls these games are fantastically
entertaining and again if you are so
inclined i highly recommend checking
this out when you get the chance
naturally everything boils down to
jodoro and joseph with joseph's
commentary hilariously bellowing
throughout the confrontation
watching this old man try to make sense
of jodo and kakuwin's approach with
these video games
was honestly hilarious and somehow araki
managed to make jotaro look
like a boss while playing a video game
for what i think was his very first time
naturally joturo wins the day and with
that said this brings to a close the
warm-up portion
of this story next up the final hurdle
before dio
the final obstacle and it's a doozy
vanilla ice this this is where the fun
and games stopped both figuratively
and literally unlike the flamboyant and
playfully dangerous nature the vast
majority of these stand users have been
vanilla ice is a devout follower of dio
is his right hand man
and totally psychotic and interestingly
all the while
jotaro caccumine and joseph were trapped
playing darby the player's twisted games
abdul polynerif and iggy fell prey to a
much more
insidious fate
this fight specifically shows the true
power of stardust crusaders over the
last 130 some odd chapters we have gone
on the adventure of a lifetime with
these characters we've gotten to know
all of them with some standing out more
so than others from japan to hong kong
to india to pakistan
through conflict disaster and loss we've
followed and gotten to know each and
every
one of these individuals as true heroes
and now for the last time
iggy abdul and polynomial enter a battle
together impressing upon us the
ruthlessness and powers vanilla ice has
in store for these warriors without
hesitation and by way of blindsiding in
an attempt to take out both polaris and
abdul vanilla ice launches a deadly
attack
the type of battle that takes place here
is unlike anything we've seen from this
part before and i'd wager the entire
series up until this point the level of
paneling in this part
the connection we feel towards the
characters and the torture we see on
screen that made me feel extremely
uncomfortable at times
are truly new heights met by this series
from abdul's emotional sacrifice to
iggy's giving polymeric a second
chance at life two fantastic characters
that made me truly feel something
perhaps even more so than caesar in part
two this is
stardust crusaders at its absolute best
and to think
we still have dio to contend with dio
brando
with the stage set treacherously by
vanilla ice our heroes totally out of
the loop
clueless as to what has just transpired
holly on her deathbed and dio now at
full power
these are but a few of the pieces placed
by iraqi in this final volume within the
stardust crusade having spent what felt
like an age with the characters of
polymer of abdul and even iggy to a
large extent to say i was feeling severe
melancholy after the events that just
transpired battle wise
would be an understatement having been
hidden behind a series of intense
shadows for the last nine volumes
this volume this final volume this page
this is the moment we finally get to see
dio
the final boss of stardust crusaders
this is the moment
the last three parts and 265 chapters
this battle this is the one that has
defined three generations of joestar and
it's
all coming to a head now
pictured atop a staircase full to the
brim with both confidence poise and
power
stands dio and at the bottom limping his
way towards what he believes to be
certain doom
is his one-time follower turned deserter
polymerase through this sequence araki
demonstrates his exemplary paneling and
storyboard creating a very specific
atmosphere
and that's not the only technique
implemented in this scene that builds
its tension and power
forever intimidating dio seems to have
gotten into the mind of palmer of who
after climbing to the stairs
seems to be traveling down it or is
there something more sinister
underneath the surface going on here
polyriff seems to have made up his mind
he isn't joining him but it isn't
looking good and
that's when we see it dio stand
[Music]
drowning the scene in a pool of light
dancing up the stairs towards dio he is
forced to flee
farther into the shadows the gangs back
together
time to go kill the ultimate vampire and
i am all for it
you would think that all the build up
this character has received would feel
unjustified but as i was reading through
these chapters the sense that this was
truly a story spanning lifetimes felt
overwhelming i can't stress just how
gorgeous and well orchestrated the
following events are paneled or just how
clear it was how much
effort and planning went into its design
the circumstances and set pieces
involved in what would eventually be the
final fight scene of the arc make up the
absolute without any hesitation from me
or i call the very best material
contained in jojo's bizarre adventure
that i've seen kicking things off dio
cuts through the town
single-handedly taking out caccuwine
without learning the nature of his stand
a vital piece of information however
just as joseph is about to tango with
the prince of darkness
suddenly
this is vital little does joseph know
that he's just received a massive hint
as a result of kakuwin's dying effort
i loved this dynamic with these two
supporting characters
in that it fulfills khakiway's character
in wanting to stand up for what he
believes in and overcomes his fear in
the face of his former master
showing his growth over the journey and
now we rely on joseph joestar's defining
characteristic his intelligence
to decipher and relay this very
important piece of information
to jotaro and he uses his hammond with
his stand
in a really cool way it's a great idea
so my day was made with that decision
[Music]
once again as a character that purposely
has been shown to emote very little
in this instance when he witnesses the
potential death of his grandfather
the one stone-cold expression of jodaro
starts to show a fleeting
but definitely present crack on its
surface and this fight that ensues is
unlike any i've ever
seen in not only the series but perhaps
any other fight i've
ever watched araki makes 100
full use of the mechanic in ways so
creative it carves out a special place
in my heart this
is a true fight of good versus evil and
it uses that to its advantage in every
way
imaginable and conceivable and then
invents new ways for dio to cut through
the crew like a chainsaw cuts through
butter
moments prior when he eventually fights
the last jojo standing in his way when
we see him show
genuine concern facing this cujo jodaro
as the fight proceeds
my stress has translated so readily to
that of relief and desire
to cheer on jodaro now i'm not sure how
much of a role
2020 has played in my enjoyment and
appreciation of this story but
a core element of what helped me enjoy
this more than i thought it would is
its lack of nuance with regards to a
good versus evil type story
all over popular media now there's an
abundance of villains propagating our
screens with motivations that can be
justified through their warped and
sometimes justifiable vision of the
world
this is something i greatly appreciate
when it comes to storytelling and i
still do to a large extent today
however i think partially due to the
complexity negativity and disaster after
disaster that 2020 brought to all of our
attentions i realized
i needed something different i needed
something straightforward simple
and heroic to get behind a story
spanning generations
culminating in this moment where
jonathan's grandson and
great-great-grandson
find themselves facing insurmountable
odds against the epitome of evil
dio brando a villain that while pure
evil
adds so much to the story in way of
weight consequence
design and goal that goal being
defeat dio and save the world and that
is absolutely something i can get behind
and you know what else i can get behind
this ridiculously fantastic strategy
that employs all of jonah's best
attributes to get this skull shattering
shut off on dio
he stops his own heart to lull him into
a false sense of security
and boom i don't think i've seen a punch
more satisfying than that one
right there in this entire series easily
my favorite punch and to be honest i
don't think i could speak or gush enough
about this final battle it feels
fittingly evocative of every emotion
araki has tried to bring forth from me
and is easily my favorite part of this
entire series
it features some revolutionary action
sequences and ideas that even now
reading through in 2021 feels like it
could work if released last
week it's truly timeless the back and
forth is amazing with jotaro slowly
bending deal to his will forcing him to
take more and more desperate and
underhanded measures
but eventually through sheer will and
determination
jonaro annihilates dio the plague that
has haunted his family for generations
has finally been vanquished and it was
incredible
this series jojo's bizarre adventure was
one i was incredibly reluctant to dive
into earlier this month but i am so
incredibly happy
that i have and not just that but that
i've shared it with all of you
thank you all so much for your amazing
support in this series and
it's not over next week is entirely
uncharted territory for me
when i tackle jojo's bizarre adventure
diamond is unbreakable
part four so what are we waiting for
let's dive right no no no no no in
[Laughter]
[Music]
you